welcome
um i'm nicola fousey i'm a researcher
in microsoft research in new england uh
in cambridge massachusetts and i want to
welcome you to this talk which is
presented by the ottoman research
community at msr
frank's talk is the second in our series
this year on directions in machine
learning
automl and automating algorithms for
more information including our speaker
lineup and video archive you can go to
aka dot ms slash
demo written as d-i-m-l
so frank is a full professor of machine
learning at the university
of freiburg in germany as well the chief
expert otamel at the bosch center for
artificial intelligence
he holds a phd from the university of
british columbia and a master of science
from tu darmstadt
in the field of autumnal frank quarter
the icml workshop series knows
ml in 2014 and has co-organized it every
year since
he also quoted the prominent automl
tools auto weka and auto sklearn
won the first two automotive challenges
with his themes coter the first book on
automl
worked extensively on efficient type of
parameter optimization and new
architecture search
and gave an europe's 2018 tutorial with
over 3000 attendees
today he's going to talk about neural
architecture search
coming of age this talk is going to be
about 45 minutes long and it will we
will have a 15 minutes
live q a after the recording of this
talk will be publicly available but the
q a will not be recorded as it's for
attending the live
event only so feel free to write
questions in the chat as you think of
them
and frank will either answer them live
in the chat or we'll save them for the
moderated q a
thank you and enjoy thanks nicolo um for
the nice introduction and for inviting
me to give a talk here
so my talk today is titled neural
architecture search
coming of age and i basically going to
give
a description of several different works
in neural architecture search
that i think are really cool and how
the field as such is well coming of age
one quick note all these slides um are
available
at www.automl.org
talks and all the references i have in
the talk
are hyperlinks so if you get the pdf you
can get directly to
all the different papers by clicking on
them
all right so to start off um let me
mention that neural architecture search
really is exploding um we
wrote the survey in well end of 2018
published in 2019 when it was um
yeah still a manageable field and the
number of publications that came out
in 2019 were already four times more
than in 2018 and that factor already was
there before and this is 2016
is when this paper neural architecture
search for reinforcement learning
was published at iclear by um sophen lee
and that's really when neural
architecture search hit mainstream
and since then it's really exploding
however neural architecture search is
still in the process
of overcoming some childhood problems it
hasn't fully come
off age yet so there was this iclear
2020 paper
nas evaluation is frustratingly hard
which showed that
well just by playing with the different
um yeah settings of your training
pipeline you can get better and better
and better and better performance
so a total difference of something like
three percent
just by playing with your settings of
the untraining pipeline
such as adding drop drop pass and cut
out and auxiliary
towers and more channels and using auto
augment and more epochs
um and so this is three percent
difference going from here to there
and the architecture space well that's
just something like one percent
different or half a percent
so um that doesn't shed a great light on
your architecture search
but um nevertheless neural architecture
search
has led to much better architectures
being available now
than previously
another issue in your architecture
search is that while the community is
quite focused
on tables like this with performance
numbers like this
and i would argue that all these numbers
are just really incomparable
due to this issue of the settings being
really important because all of these
different papers
where with these being reported test
errors in the different papers
use different training code different
hyper parameters
different search spaces different
evaluation schemes so this is really
very incomparable
and just how good a performance you get
on c410
doesn't really mean much about
how good is your meta algorithm your
neural architecture circuit algorithm
and i would very much advocate
for disentangling these two
and that brings me to the overview
the first part that i'm going to talk
about is actually about best practices
and benchmarks
for neural architecture search in order
to really help the field
completely come of age and be a
scientific field
with good principles the second part
is about speed up techniques for neural
architecture search because
well the original were by by soft and
lee or it's reinforcement learning well
that that used 800 gpus
for several weeks and
well of course that is not something
that we can do
on an everyday basis for all kinds of
different problems in academia
and not even an industry so speed up
techniques are very important and this
will actually
really be the biggest part of the talk
um there will be four different speed up
techniques i'll talk about
um then i'll briefly talk about
autopilot
which helps us to actually jointly
search in the space of neural
architectures
and hyper parameters in order to really
give us um
off-the-shelf auto ml so something that
that
can be fairly hands-free and
finally i'll briefly talk about an
extended problem formulation where we
don't search for just a single
architecture but for
a whole ensemble of neural architectures
all right let's jump right in and talk
about benchmarks and best practices
the first benchmark that we introduced
back then
in back then one year ago at icml
was nasbench101 so this is
a relatively small search space that we
exhaustively evaluated in order to
enable researchers to afterwards
do work on neural architecture search
where
if you would normally query the
performance of
a neural architecture you now go and
look it up in a table
and so the table lookup takes um less
than a second
and you can then run architecture search
experiments on the laptop in minutes
rather than taking 800 gpus for weeks
this clearly enables proper scientific
research now we can do multiple runs now
we can do robustness studies
and get statistical significance and we
can also do
fair head-to-head evaluations by design
because
well you you don't have a possibility to
actually tweak
the training pipeline because well the
values are just saved in the table
and well of course the source code and
the scripts
are available for this as well for
anyone to
start from it and continue um
a few more details so there we looked at
000 architectures this is a very small
cell search space
but um it's still all quite large in
absolute terms so 400 000
networks being evaluated and the
important thing is this
is had to be done once and nobody has to
run these 400 000 architectures
again and this was really only possible
with
large-scale industrial resources we did
this project together with google
and used 4 000 tpus for several months
so yeah thanks for all that compute time
that was very helpful
some things that we can do with such a
benchmark is well actually
properly compare different optimizers
and we did that in the nas bench 101
paper
and there we saw that well we compared
hyperband and random search smack tpe
regularized evolution bob and
reinforcement learning
and noticed that well regularized
evolution
actually is better than reinforcement
learning is better than random search
but bayesian optimization is um here
just as good as regularized evolution
and notice that the smack algorithm here
that was actually published in 2011
and that outperforms rl that was
published in 2016
um but of course um
nobody would tell the people on stuff
and lee in 2016 oh
um can you please compare this against
smack or compare this against these
other 10 baselines because well 800 gpus
for multiple weeks
you can't run this many times and even
their own algorithm they ran a single
time 800
gpus for several weeks now if
now that we have these tabular
benchmarks we can actually trivially run
all of these algorithms many times on
each of the
lines here is based on 500 runs on
taking
the mean of those and yeah we can do
these scientific studies
using these tabular benchmarks so
they're really extremely useful
um there has been follow-up tabular
benchmarks um
one actually um from my own group where
we
took subspaces of naspbench 101
that have been fully evaluated
because nusbench 101 has this problem
that
well even though we had 423 000
architectures
we couldn't cover an entire
search space and completely but we had a
constraint
that we would only allow at most nine
edges in this
directed at graph that describes the
cell architecture
and um if you try to use 10 edges or
more
then well there's just no architecture
evaluated for that
and so you can't evaluate one-shot
models that would
require evaluations of
all the possible instantiations of the
search space and
what we did in nassbang one short one is
actually to look at subspaces of
naspbench 101
that are fully evaluated and work for
one shot
method and there we have three different
subspaces that
have respectively six thousand and
twenty nine thousand and three hundred
sixty three thousand architectures
so still quite large and those work for
one shot methods and that's why it's
called nas bench one shot one
um at the same time uh nas bench two or
one came out
um by johnny dong and ninja
and their approach was a bit different
they actually came up with a new neural
architecture benchmark
that had very few unique architectures
only 6000 compared to 420 000
but the search space was very
nice very clearly aligned with the
typical
search spaces that you would use for
one-shot methods
and therefore it's very convenient to
benchmark your one shot methods
and what's also very nice is that they
have three data sets
you can do meta learning experiments on
this and
they have the entire learning curve
logged so you can do learning curve
extrapolation
and things like that on this data set
now one problem of all of these nas
benchmarks
is still that they're too small to be
realistic even this 423 thousand
architecture series
is very very small compared to larger
search spaces
that are realistic and and indeed it has
been shown that local search
is actually state of the art for these
tabular benchmarks but performs very
poorly on large spaces
so we're not quite at the point where we
can really design our methods to work
well on these tabular spaces
and then be quite sure that they're
going to work well
on the real benchmarks
and here comes the first contribution
that i want to talk about
a bit more this is an archive paper that
actually came out today
and it's not bench 301 and the
new thing here is that this is really
the first benchmark that's for a
realistic nas space
namely exactly the one of the darts
paper
so this has 10 to the 18 architectures
compared to the well
10 to the how much is
less than 10 to the 6 here um
so more than a factor of 10 to the 12
more architectures and of course the
space is ridiculously large
we can't exhaustively evaluate um
in this space and what we do rather is
to
actually fit a surrogate model rather
than a tabular benchmark
so this works as follows we just observe
partial results we observe
a lot of different architectures in the
search space and then we put a
regression model
to use instead of using a table and this
regression model can of course
extrapolate to unseen architectures
surprisingly maybe at first glance this
can yield
better estimates of the true performance
than a tabular benchmark
and the reason for that is as follows so
tabular benchmarks
actually still have noise and they're
typically based on
only one or very few runs per
architecture
and these runs well they're running sgd
sgd is a stochastic algorithm and it
yields
quite different performance in different
runs
so you by by just
trusting the result of a single run
you're gonna have an approximation error
of the true
underlying performance of this
architecture and
if you view tabular benchmarks from a
machine learning perspective from a
statistical
estimation perspective then basically
what they are
is their models that assume
complete independence of the performance
of all the different architectures
and only put all that x in the one
basket of
this one run or the very few runs for an
architecture a
that we saw exactly before so
um when you when you want to predict for
or
look at the performance of our
architecture a
then you look at exactly the run for
architecture a and no other runs of
similar
architectures however we know that there
is large noise
in sgd and we know that the performance
of similar architectures actually is
similar so from a machine learning
perspective it makes a lot of sense
that a model that doesn't make this
independence assumption
could actually do better and smooth out
this noise and precisely that's what we
see here on the right
this is actually running on nas bench
where we have actually three evaluations
per
architecture not just one and what we
look at here is the error that you would
make if you just trust one run
by looking at how different are the
other two runs from this one run
so the two runs are the ground truths
and the one run is the estimate
and we compare this ground truth to
this this estimate or to the estimate of
a surrogate model
fit on a different number of
architectural runs
with also just that one seed and
if you use that one seed for all the
architectures and you fit a model on it
then your error is actually less than
just trusting the single architecture
um the single run of the architecture
and the
break-even point is actually somewhere
at about 15 000 architectures
that you need to evaluate out of these
423 cells
and then then your surrogate model
actually can generate
can generalize to architectures that are
not in this training set
right so what did we do to build last
band 301
we evaluated 50 000 architectures in the
darts search space
and we evaluated them using different
optimizers because well we want to cover
the whole
search space roughly and we did that
using random search with 24
000 evaluations and we wanted to cover
good parts of the space and we didn't
really want to put our all our eggs in
one basket
so we ran different methods such as
evolution differential evolution
regularized evolution
tpe bananas combo and a variety of
different one-shot methods
in order to collect the architectures
that we would then evaluate
in order to to really find the good
architectures in this space
and because those are the ones that we
will want to
look at a lot when we do optimization in
the space
we then evaluated a broad range of
different regression models to fit this
data
and what we found was that the best
regression models were actually gradient
boosting
or graph convolutional neural networks
so
and the graph convolutional networks
were better on some paths and the
gradient will sing
better on some other tasks and the
details for that are are in the paper
but the important thing to notice is
that we can actually fit this data and
just like for
nas bench 101 our estimation errors
are actually lower than the error that's
due to the noise in a single run of sgd
so even if we could fit a tabular
benchmark
on these 10 to the 18 different
configurations
the estimated error of that
would be higher than the estimated error
of our model and of course that we can
only show that for
the architectures that are in our test
set
but those are um yeah tens of thousands
of architectures
so um we trust it um quite a bit
all right what can we do with last bench
301 well very similar things as with
lastbench101 we can for example
benchmark different math methods
and so we can look at the performance of
these methods on the true benchmark
and here we have one run or we can look
at the
performance on the surrogate benchmark
so here
um a evaluating an architecture takes
several hours here evaluating an
architecture takes less than a second
and nevertheless the evaluations the
qualitative results are very similar
so you you see that random search for
example it is up here it's not doing
very well
also not doing very well here we can for
the surrogates actually
play time longer than for these
for the true benchmark the true
benchmark we couldn't run any longer
because well actually
this x scale here goes to 3 times 10 to
the 7
seconds that's 30 million seconds which
is
um or 32 million seconds actually more
than a gpu
year and this is a single run of
these neural architecture search methods
um if you run
random sequentially random and paralyzed
fashion otherwise you couldn't have done
that at all
and here we can nevertheless say oh well
what if we ran this 10 times longer we
would
get the following performance random
search still wouldn't um
go anywhere and um while re
just got better here and then it would
probably
stay roughly there we see that here
bananas
based on optimization with neural
networks does really well and the same
is reflected also
in the surrogate benchmarks tpe is
not doing much better than random search
same in the surrogate benchmarks
d e is doing
quite well in the end um this is the
same as here
and this is just the continuation so
really
very qualitatively similar results uh
the one difference here in the
in the surrogate benchmarks and the true
benchmark is that
the performance is smoother on the
surrogates well then that is the case
because we could only afford one run
here and we have many runs here and
report averages
so overall benchmarking on the surrogate
is really something that
looks very similar to the performance on
the original darts benchmark
and we can do it quite cheaply now
the availability of these different nas
benchmarks combined with
the note on mass evaluation as
frustratingly hard that i mentioned in
the beginning
led us to propose these best practices
for neural architecture search so we
we very much encourage people to release
their code
not just the trained architectures but
also
code to actually do uh the training
to to see what are the tricks that are
being used
um in in the different papers as we saw
in the nasa evaluation is frustratingly
hard this can make up to three percent
difference
um also releasing hyper parameters
releasing seeds and so on
and then properly comparing methods that
includes using the same search spaces
using
the same nas benchmarks and using the
same enough benchmarks doesn't mean
using c410 but means using
the same search space the same
optimization pipeline and optimally the
same hyperparameters
and then also of course the same data
set and the same training and validation
test splits and everything
that belongs to a nas benchmark and
then you can actually do fair apples to
apples comparisons
and if you use some tabular surrogate
benchmarks
then then you actually get that part for
free and you can actually
do these experiments really quickly and
you can get statistical significance
on these benchmarks i'm not advocating
to only
use nas benchmarks for your evaluations
it sometimes
helps to make sure that everything does
transfer
to the true benchmarks but for all kinds
of unit
tests for all evaluations um in
intermediate evaluations
and for the evaluations in the paper
where we want to get statistical
significance
i'm definitely advocating using a lot of
tabula and surrogate benchmarks
and the third type of um yeah best
practices um concerns reporting
important details such as how much hyper
parameter tuning actually went into
a method and how robust it would be when
you run it on new data sets and so on
so this checklist is an actual checklist
um that's available
um online and the one suggestion that i
would make
based on this to reviewers is to
actually de-emphasize the final results
table on c410 and other data sets look a
little bit less at that
and be aware of the many confounding
factors that go into
those final performance numbers all
right
so to summarize this on the first part
i think we've gone a long way towards
actually building a scientific community
around here at architecture
we now have benchmarks that can be used
really cheaply also by
students who don't have access to any
big compute so this is really
something where academia can do a lot
now we have this best practice checklist
we also organize the first workshop at
iclear on your architecture search and
one thing that we're working on
where we have the first version is a
library of
ural architecture search that's modular
and extensible
and just implements all kinds of
different methods
and really enables clean empirical
comparisons
without confounding factors great so
um so much for benchmarks and best
practices and i'll now transition to the
second part of the talk
on speed up techniques for neural
architecture search
as i mentioned there will be four
different types of techniques here
the first one is on weight inheritance
and network morphisms
so network morphisms are operators
that change the network structure but
not the modeled function
so that means for every input the
network
yields the same output as before
applying the network morphers
so you have a network and then you put
in a layer
that makes this one and say this layer
here
is just an identity mapping and then the
function that's computed
by this modified architecture is still
the same as before
and you can use these network morphisms
in your architecture search algorithms
as operations to generate new networks
that you then don't need to
um train from scratch but for which you
have pre-trained
networks available that you can then
just fine-tune
and this allows doing fast architecture
search
as follows so you start from some model
um that has a certain performance and
i'm just showing here
two large layers and two small layers
and it has a certain performance
and you apply different network
morphisms for example making one layer
wider adding a layer and maybe adding a
skip connection
because these are network morphisms the
performance is going to stay exactly the
same
82 then you do some fine tuning
and the performance changes and then you
simply
pick the model that has the best
performance
and iterate this process and that
actually allows you to do surprisingly
fast architecture search
through these local operations so
something like architecture search in 12
hours
on a single gpu
one issue with this however is that
the network morph systems only ever make
your architecture
larger and you're you're never going to
get
small architectures with good
performance so
in order to get those we had this
follow-up work
on um at last year's iclear on efficient
multi-objective
architecture search through network
morphism so here
we want to trade off for example the
network size versus its error
and and we also had um different
measures in the paper
um such as um yeah the number of flops
and
and um multiple multiply add
and um yeah the well the size i already
had here and
also performance on different benchmarks
such as fifa 10
and c400 so the largest experiment we
had
actually had five um objectives
and we're interested in a pareto front
in this case here of two objectives the
number of parameters
and the validation error and we
initialize this with some
default networks one architecture here
one there one there one there
one there there one there one there and
get this pareto front where um
all the points above are dominated by a
member of the pareto front so for
example a point here
would have a validation error that's
worse than this point and would have a
number of parameters that's worse than
this point
so this we don't need to care about but
all the members of the pareto front
those are the models we would give to
the decision maker and say well these
are your options
these architectures are not dominated
and what we do here is evolve a
population of for retro-optimal
architectures over time
so we start with this generation with
this
population and over time we actually get
better performance or lower validation
error
and we also get a lower number of
parameters so we push this
hurry to front from the first generation
over time
to the lower left and um yeah
do proper multi-objective optimization
uh the resulting algorithm is called
lemonade for lamarckian evolution for
multi-objective neural architecture
design the lamarckian part
that is the inheriting the weights from
your parents
and this algorithm is still cheap um it
takes something like a week on eight
gpus
well relatively cheap for doing
multi-objective optimization
all right so far for the network
morphisms
just to mention that of course you also
can compare the resulting networks to
other mobile-sized networks
and here we have the pareto front of
lemonade
compared to nasnet this work on
reinforcement learning for neural
architecture search by soft and lee
and also different versions of mobilenet
and you get better performance
and in particular compared to naznet are
the searches 35 times faster
by using these network morphs
the same also you also get transfer to
imagenet
so no big surprises there
all right so this was weight inheritance
and network morph essence
the next speed-up technique i want to
talk about is about weight sharing and
one-shot models
and the most popular approach
in that domain is the darts algorithm or
it stands for differentiable
architecture search by leo adele
um also at iclear2019 and this works as
follows
so you have this discrete architecture
search problem
where you have operations on the edges
and you want to
choose between different operations for
each of these
edges in particular you have this option
the red
operation or the green or the blue for
example a three by three con
five by five con for max pooling etc and
what darts does it relaxes this discrete
last problem where you only can choose
one thing
to say well i'm just gonna use all the
different operations between
these edges and i'm going to put weights
on them
so that yields a mixed operator between
node i and j that is just a
weighted sum of the operations um
of the individual operations and the
weights are encapsulated by these alphas
so the alphas are these architectural
parameters and
then you can actually go
and and use gradient based optimization
in order to optimize these alphas
because the alphas are continuous values
and so you solve a bi-level optimization
problem
you look for the
alpha that gives you the minimal
validation loss
when you combine it with weights that
are optimized for this particular alpha
um weight optimized for this alpha
by optimizing training training loss
so um that that is a typical pipeline
for for hyperparameter optimization in
your architecture search we look at the
validation error
of architectures that whose weights are
trained
on the training loss and so um that's a
natural formulation that's by level
optimization
to find the architectures
that give you the best performance with
these
optimized weights for them and that goes
from here to there
so some of these edges then become a lot
stronger and some of these edges become
much weaker and the last step in darts
is to actually then
discretize each of these edges again
and drop the least important parts so
the
the lowest alphas the edges of those
just go away and only the strongest
alphas remain
and then you have just a single
architecture not this
one model anymore all right so that's a
darts approach and
this is very popular because well you
can actually
solve this by level optimization problem
by just doing a gradient step on the
alphas
followed by a gradient step on the
weights followed by a gradient step on
the alpha
and a gradient step on the weight so a
very simple algorithm there's no
proofs of convergence or anything but
but that actually works in practice
to find good architectures and weights
and because of its simplicity and
because the code is available
and this this has actually really had a
big impact in neural architecture search
now um a few things we did with starts
is we
we first actually had an application
tuning a vision pipeline
uh for depth from stereo where we have a
left image and a right image and we just
want to get this ground truth image
and well actually this is not ground
truth this is our result
um so very nice results that that we can
get by darts
and in particular we reduced the
endpoint error on zintel
by 10 from the previous state of the art
so um
quite nice uh improvements and the
previous state of the art this has
worked together with thomas brock's
group here in freiburg
who has been working on
depths from stereo for for several years
and whose
students really are experts in this and
we could nevertheless improve
the error by a relative 10 percent
um so that that goes to show darts
sometimes really works and this
is very nice but darts also has really
bad failure modes
um it often uh fails horribly returning
only to generate architectures so only
skip contacts
only parameter-less architectures and
in a paper this year's iclear
we actually showed that this behavior
consistently for 12 different neural
architecture search benchmarks every
single time
we got only skip connections and and or
only parameterless
um connections and and that of course
is just yeah very bad if you want to
think about using this in the inner loop
of an rtml system
you can't have this this sort of
behavior
um so we next looked at why this happens
and so it turns out that well the
validation error here on the left that
actually shrinks over time
that's not the problem even though this
by-level optimization there there's no
guarantee of this alternating std
that this works that actually does work
um the issue is that the curvature
um in the space actually increases
and you're running into sharp local
minima in the architectural space
so um here on the on the right we're
actually plotting the dominant eigen
value
over time and we see that that's
actually going up
as the test loss is going up over time
so first the test loss is going down
nicely but then over time it's going up
and this is because well we're going
into these
parts of the space of high curvature and
then if you recall what darts is doing
well it's doing this discretization step
so that's actually a
sizeable step in the architectural space
and if you have high curvature then
making a large space
a large step in in this architecture
space
then that actually of course gives you
really bad performance
and so that that's where the performance
loss happens it's in this discretization
step
because you have high curvature in the
local area
that you're ending up with in the
optimization and the solution
is to avoid this high curvature either
by early stopping
or by adding some amount of
regularization
using kind of any of our different
methods we tried l2
of the inner objective and we tried
scheduled drop pass both of these works
both of these avoids the high curvature
and leads to much better performance so
here is um starts on fifa 10.
it actually tuned nicely it works but as
soon as you just go to c400 with the
same
code you get very bad performance and
this robot starts get gets much better
performance
svhn similar story on ptp also similar
story
and other teams have also run this on
imagenet afterwards we didn't have the
resources for that
but got very substantial gains in
in in the image that architecture by um
using our robot starts
um and there was also a nice follow-up
paper that i
i wanted to mention because i quite
liked it
that also proposes another type of
regularization that specifically
looks at the perturbation so it's a
perturbation based regularization that
either just
adds random noise to the architectural
space
or adversarial steps and that
yielded even nicer performance so um i
here's a plug for this paper very nice
all right so this was weight sharing and
the one shot model
next i want to talk about meta learning
so learning across
data sets and in this space chelsea finn
has done a lot of very nice work and
for example proposed this model agnostic
meta learning
that has so this this inner
task where you have a task where you
compute a loss and you update your task
rates with hdd
but then there's also this outer loss
where you update your
meta weights that um
where you try to find an initialization
of
networks such that if you do a few inner
task
optimization steps you get good
performance for different tasks
and how can you combine that with neural
architecture search well
one related work that by by kim adele
would be to simply put neural
architecture search around this
and and that works because well there
there is an architecture in here and you
can
well just do a search on that neural
architecture
um however that that is getting quite
expensive
and what we did instead is we actually
merged the architecture optimization in
here
and in here so
we in the outer loss we update the meta
weights and the meta architecture
and then for the task at hand
we actually do fine tuning of the
architecture
together with fine-tuning of the weights
and
that approach called metamask actually
um
is much cheaper than than this prior
work and deals
clear new state-of-the-art results so
here's a table from the paper that's
sort of the
table reviewers want to see with
completely incomparable
methods well not method but completely
incomparable
pipelines so different training pipeline
and different hyper parameters
that we still do best because we did a
lot of engineering for it
here is the more scientifically honest
comparison with the same training
pipeline and the same hyper parameters
for well this original reptile algorithm
and then
reptile with the neural architecture so
it wrapped around
and reptile with the neural architecture
switch together
with the individual weights and
yeah this approach is also 10 times
faster than this approach and
yields the best performance in most
cases
especially if you run it for longer than
actually in all cases
it gets the best performance
all right so that's what i want to say
about meta learning
and then the last speed up technique i
want to mention is multi-fidelity
optimization
so the key idea here is to
use cheap approximations of the black
box
such that the performance of these
on these cheap approximations correlates
with the performance on the expensive
black box
um you could have all kinds of different
cheap approximations
um for example you could use subsets of
data or fewer epochs of iterative
training algorithms
or you could downsample your images you
would use shorter mcmc
chains and basic deep learning or in
deep reinforcement learning
you could use your trials
and the simplest method you could use
here is success of having
this is shown here on the right
for a wall clock time as a budget
it's a very simple algorithm that
basically says take
a bunch of different um configurations
architectures or hyper parameter
settings it doesn't really matter
train them for a while look at the worst
half and the best half and
the worst half you just cut off the best
half you continue running
and then you double the budget and look
here again cut off the worst half
let the rest running double the budget
cut off the worst half let the rest
running
and you end up with very good
architectures
that you have put quite a bit of time in
but you haven't put all this time into
these weaker architectures and you've
saved a lot of time
so that's a very nice very simple
approach
there are many more complex methods
including some
some by ours by ourselves combining this
with bayesian optimization
and so on but in the end actually the
the
combination of success of having or its
extension of hyperband
um that i would um advocate
is is to combine this with bayesian
optimization in a very simple
manner where you basically
use hyperband but you don't
or success of having but you change one
thing
namely which configurations you actually
put in where success is having in the
original
version actually looks at random
configurations
we sample these with basic optimization
and that
gives much better performance for longer
running runs
so just one quick uh showcase
of multifidelity in action um i showed
this result here earlier where we used
nas with darts
to improve um state-of-the-art
performance on zintel by 10
afterwards we actually applied bob to
this
and got another 10 reduction on top so
um
and and this is um at a run time that's
definitely less than an order of
magnitude than a standard black box
methods
all right going on to the last two
points which are relatively short so
autopi torch
is a method for join neural architecture
certain hyperparameter optimization
and it's it's kind of follow-up of our
first work on autonet
which actually did join here at arctic
research and hyperparameter optimization
back in 2015 and actually to the best of
my knowledge was the first automatic
deep learning system that that won a
machine learning competition data set
against human experts so there it got
area under the curve of 0.9 whereas the
best team
of human experts and there were more
than these 10 actually only got 0.8
and um they had something like two
months in a kaggle
um style challenge um to to tackle this
data set
so that was already a quite nice um
showcase back then
back then it was relatively slow with
black box optimization and in the
meantime
now we're actually using multifidelity
optimization and we're using meta
learning
to warm start this process across data
sets and this is
a work in an archive paper earlier this
year
so yeah and actually this is also open
source
and we haven't been pushing this for a
long time so um but
given that we've only been pushing this
for about half a year
um i think it's it's finding a big
following already
so um in brief this is
um the design space for autopilot tabula
for tabular data we use
a so called shaped resnet so
and we also look at mlps where we
basically configure the number of blocks
and the number of groups as you would
for residual networks
and well residual networks are typically
used for convolutional neural networks
but there's nothing that is holding us
back from also using residual
connections
for tabular data and we do and it
actually helps it's quite a bit better
than the mlp nets
um so the design space is relatively
small we only have something like 12
um architectural choices and 12 hyper
parameters
so about a dozen each and here's how we
search this
we do multi-fidelity metal learning so
multifidelity optimization with bob
we have as much as the number of sgd
epochs
this is 12 25 or 50 so actually
relatively small
and so we can only get something like a
speed up of four because the cheapest
budget is only four times smaller than
the
most expensive budget but nevertheless
we actually often get this factor of
four
um sometimes only in the beginning
sometimes
um we would get overtaken in the end by
optimizing only on the full data set
but sometimes actually even after a long
time bob is still quite a bit faster
than blackbox vo
and the the more important contribution
here
is to actually also use meta learning so
to initialize
the search with complementary
configurations that cover a lot of
previous data sets
so what we did here is to look at 100
different data sets
and look at what are the
instantiations of autopilot that would
do well
on these previous data sets and make
sure that we get a set of complementary
configurations using our greedy
submodular optimization
and we also compared this against the
simple portfolio where we
would just put 100 configurations that
did best on each of the previous
data sets and sometimes a simple
portfolio is just as good as our
submodular build portfolio and both of
them are a lot better than bob
and sometimes well this uh smarter way
of building the portfolio is actually
very important compared to this simpler
way
and then in all cases definitely the
warm starting helps a lot
to the orders of magnitude faster than
um just basic optimization with
multifidelity
here's an evaluation against other
optoml frameworks
and here we do really well compared to
auto keras and auto scale learn
and hyper opt sklearn and we are doing
further evaluations right now
on the opeml or term l benchmark
so that's 39 data sets that were
collected by
different people and we also do an
evaluation against auto glue and with
the auto glue and team in order to make
sure that everything is fair in that
comparison
one might wonder whether the same
approaches also work for image data and
actually yes they do so we evaluated
this on lastbench201
where we have three datasets c410 c400
and downsampled imagenet
and so we really only have two datasets
that we can train
on a metatrain on and one to meta test
on
and even though we only have data from
these two previous data sets
um the warm sighting really helps a lot
the multi-fidelity optimization here
doesn't help because there is actually
quite weak correlations
across budgets in nashville 201 but
the warm starting here gives you one to
two orders of magnitude
speed up over yeah
just on doing basic optimization or bob
by themselves and
actually if you compare this to
gradient-based math
it actually is something like four times
faster to reach ninety percent on cfar
so doing this multi-fidelity method
learning actually gets you to the realm
of being extremely competitive with
gradient-based neural architecture
search
and here you have the advantage you can
trivially put in
a few hyper parameters and optimize them
exactly the same way
that we optimize also the neural
architecture
all right that brings me almost to the
end i just have um i think three more
slides about this extended problem
formulation on your ensemble search
so here the motivation is as follows on
ensembling
often improves the performance of neural
networks we all know that
and recent results also actually show
that if you use an ensemble of a neural
network
just 10 copies of the neural network
that
we're just 10 and instantiations of sgd
and the different minima
found that actually gives you a very
nice predictive uncertainty
and also robustness to distributional
shift and in particular better results
than all the bayes and deep learning
methods out there
typically and but that that seems
suboptimal because diversity among the
base learners
predictions is really key for strong
ensembles and
achieving diversity through different
architectures hasn't been studied so far
so so all that they did is take a single
good architecture
and take multiple copies of that and
what we do
what we propose is to actually use
neural architecture search
to search for strong ensembles of
diverse architecture so
this is not directly encoded that we
want them to be diverse
but in order to be complementary and
give good ensemble performance
they automatically become diverse
so here i visualize that different
architectures actually
give you diverse predictions so here's
five different architectures and their
predictions in a disney encoding
and here is
several different architectures found by
neural ensemble search
and here is the on the same problem
the deep ensemble so this is a single
architecture
a single good architecture and we see
the diversity here is much smaller
in the predictions than the diversity in
the architectures coming from nest and
this results actually also in better
performance because greater diversity
helps to to reduce errors so
here we look at um the
neural ensemble search as the number of
networks evaluated
becomes larger and larger so as the
search progresses
um with three or so um three
architectures in the ensemble five
architectures 10 architectures and 30
architectures
and likewise for deep ensembles based on
the architecture found by darts
and the architecture found by a movement
maybe a net
um which is actually quite a bit larger
than the architectures that
um we look at and nevertheless we can um
do
quite a bit better than i'm within it
especially
um when we allowed many many members in
our population because of the
diversity in our ensemble members
we can also directly optimize for robust
predictions under data shift
and if we do that then
we actually become i'm very robust to
um to these um yeah
data shifts and we get very nice
uncertainty estimate
and much better than deep ensembles and
yeah also
actually achieve state-of-the-art
performance for robust predictions under
data shift
all right that brings me to the end the
takeaways i would like you to
take away with you is that neural
architecture search is really coming of
age there's a lot of cool stuff
happening
there's a scientific community forming
around neural architecture search that
everybody can
become involved in now there is open
source
there is benchmarks and best practices
there's a ton of different ways in order
to speed up neural architecture search
so we don't need you to compute clusters
anymore in order to do interesting
research
and this also becomes practical
now so octopi chart really tackles joint
neural architecture search and
hyperparameter optimization
and well you can also apply this i'm in
this extended formulation to
find great ensembles there's links to
code
and um there's a book on your
architecture search with that i would
like to thank you very much
for your attention and also many things
to finding sources and especially to my
fantastic team
so thanks a lot
great thank you for the incredible talk
it's
it's a head spinning amount of of work
that you put in there
um and it was really really interesting
to see like the different aspects you
touched on
very interesting aspects from nass work
to hyperplanet optimization to join nasa
and hyperventilate optimization to meta
learning
to ensembling uh with mass it's super
interesting
uh we had i mean quite quite a large
amount of questions
that you uh i guess you didn't get bored
during this talk in replying to all of
those
um it's like it was actually quite
frenetic i think uh to want to to
stay you know stay up to speed with what
was coming in
but one thing that i wanted to do and
while people can
can keep throwing questions in the q a
i'm i'm keeping an eye on it and if they
have them
i'm going to ask them live uh but in the
meanwhile
we have kind of like a block of
questions on nasb301 301
that came in from different people and i
kind of have my own and i want to kind
of bring them all in into one single
question so
let me start with a string of questions
from the dip today
um uh who's asking about uh you know in
301 50 000 architectures are used for
training the predictor
um and uh oh it's
beyond the 25 000 randomly sampled
architecture
uh you also add the pathway of popular
nas algorithms doesn't this make the
predictor
biased and i think you answered in the
chat but would be useful i think because
it's an interesting question to answer
them
here as well and then i'm going to ask
the follow-up and then i follow up and
then i follow up
yeah okay great um yeah those are those
are very good questions about last page
301 and of course i um
only talked about it for a few minutes
and we have a lot of experiments in the
paper
that answer a lot of these questions um
it is a good point we can't cover this
um space
exhaustively well because it's i'm 10 to
the
um i forgot the exact number i'm 40 or
10 18. in this case only and another
version has 10 to the 23.
but so it's huge we can't possibly do
this
um and so we're going to miss some and
we're really trying to think of what are
the best architectures to evaluate in
order to cover our bases in order to
cover
all the different parts
that we need in order to make a good
mass benchmark and
a good nas benchmark of course i i think
needs to
be kind of good in the interesting areas
nas optimizers try to find good
architectures and i think that's why we
should
actually try to make particularly good
predictions for the good architectures
for the bad architectures well one could
argue
for example for these robustness issues
of darts
it's really important to actually also
cover that and to not just say well
that's a
relatively bad one but to say that
that's a really really bad one
and that is a failure mode that we know
and because of that we actually did put
and i didn't talk about that
but we did put additional training data
in there from
all kinds of architectures that are
derived from
other architectures and then add in more
and more parameter less operations
so more skip connections more
um yeah more max pooling and so on
in order to make these architectures
worse and get better training data from
that
and and we actually um still need to do
an ablation study to see on how much
that helped but i'm sure that helped for
these i'm very bad architectures to show
that they're very bad
um i don't think that without these
really bad architectures we would see
any differences in the rankings
of the different nas optimizers and and
i think that's
um one of the things that that while
people tend to
do a lot with last benchmarks is to rank
different methods
and and also in terms of the bias well
it's biased in the sense
that you make good predictions for the
architectures
that you trained on it's not biased in
the sense
that you're predicting the architectures
that you trained on to be good
um so you're actually getting better for
those
and for others that you haven't trained
on or your uncertainty is larger
and you might potentially make larger
errors if
if there are some parts of the space
that nobody has ever
considered and um that we don't have
training data on
and there the extrapolation error would
be larger and the uncertainty is larger
we also have uncertainty estimates
i see yeah so so that's interesting so
you touch detached on this in your
answer but there is a follow-up question
where uh which was asking if we bias the
population to the good architectures
then the predictor may extrapolate good
performer
performance in areas where the
architectures are actually bad
at a higher level i'm wondering if we
can move away this is the second part of
the question can move away from c410 and
want to create say
301 for data set x how should we go
about selecting architectures
um yeah so so we're trying to come up
with the best way to select
architectures in order to cover our
bases and
um i would actually be very um
interested in
people knowing other failure modes that
we
could and should actually um cover
in our data collection and i think one
part that's really important
is that we should um always be open to
add additional data to the benchmark and
because of that we
we set up versioning and we're not just
going to change the benchmark um
without telling anyone because then we
get incomparable numbers between
different papers
but on paper should then compare on like
version one against version one version
two against version two and or
one point seven three against one point
seven three um in order
to train on the same architectures um
and i i think we've
well we thought of everything that we
could think of and i'm i'm
relatively confident that we thought of
most things i
can't say that we thought of all and
there might well be some some things
that we haven't thought of
um and that there might be ways of of um
coming up with other architectures that
are really interesting to train on
actually one thing that um we still do
want to do is
that that will take more compute again
is to actually run
the basically run an optimization on the
surrogate
and look at the architectures that are
predicted to be best by the surrogate
and then evaluate those add them back to
the model
in order to sort of converge in order to
verify that the model is not predicting
anything to be
far better than it actually is we don't
have any indication that that is
happening but
um we haven't run this iterative process
mostly due to compute
issues but yeah we're still yeah i guess
to do more
that was one of my questions as well
like could you like so if
we are going to ask more questions about
the fidelity and 301
and the surrogate model but in theory if
the surrogate model is that good
couldn't use that as a prior in a gp for
instance to then do basic optimization
and then you can basically you know
you know probably should reduce the
sample complexity quite a bit
right because because if the surrogate
is so good you can do a double surrogate
in some sense
yeah i mean of course you could cheat
and say
well i'm gonna define a new algorithm to
search on the dot search space and put
in 50 000 data points on the start
search space
well i don't know you don't want to do
that um
if you then go to a different search
base or different benchmark and so on
well then that's more meta learning and
that's
well that's fair game yeah it's just we
um
did a lot of the data collection that
you would need to do in order to do
proper metal learning
and we've only done it on one data set
again i'm due to compute yeah
but um but i didn't want to um
give the impression at all that well nas
bench 301
is the be all and end all um
benchmark but i think it will be the
first um surrogate benchmark in
a lot a long line of different circuit
benchmarks because
well we have just been tying our hands
behind our back
to stick with these tabular benchmarks
where we need to actually evaluate
everything
and well there we have seen that there's
also errors that you make by actually
only having
very few evaluations and that you can
actually from a machine learning
perspective just do better if you
actually use machine learning rather
than actually just look at um
use a lookup table and you exploit the
fact that
while you have smoothness across
architectures and so on
yeah that's it what i was suggesting i
don't know if it would even
count as cheating if you evaluate 50 000
darts architectures right
in some sense when you're designing a
search method a new search method you do
run
a bunch of trials maybe you don't
evaluate as many as fifty thousand but
you do run the bench tutorials then
incorporate that knowledge
into your design of your search method
it wouldn't be a super and also then
people use these
search spaces for years like you know
dart you know
i mean if if you did do this on on the
dart search space for c410 then
well i would argue you're looking at
your test data um during training right
because
right i can give you in zero seconds an
awesome architecture
that's true i guess i guess if you don't
go the full 50 times if you do like
300 that yeah and i mean that's the sort
of stuff you you can use that as the
initial design for your base
optimization or something like that
um yeah you can get that for free that
makes perfect sense
i mean not for free you should count the
runtime and and we
did of course the run time that it took
in order to run these
um so you can on the x axis put the
simulated wall called time
yeah now that that's great um
there was a follow-up question by
nathaniel holtz uh who was asking
could you comment on the fidelity of the
surrogate model given the cost of
exhaustively evaluating the dart search
base is prohibitive
sparsity is clear and avoidable
nevertheless 50 000 architectures
is less than 10 to 18 as a corollary is
such a
sparse prediction task can be accurately
performed does it suggest that much of
the dart search space is redundant
um well i i think redundant is
is a harsh word there is regularity in
there and there is smoothness
it like we also looked at um some some
experiments that i didn't talk about
looking at if you increase the number of
mux pooling if you increase the skip
connections um and there are
regularities that
typically well it only gets worse that
the more parameters
operations you put in except a few skip
connections are useful
and um yeah we can call that redundant
you can call it the
performance factors into
smaller smaller pieces that you can use
in order to actually make these
predictions and that's not
that's not um too surprising i find i
mean um
otherwise we as humans couldn't really
make sense of these spaces
and we can use models like this in order
to actually
yeah find these regularities and then
of course we only find them in the model
we only find them in these 50 000 data
points
then we actually also need to go and
verify that these hold on on test data
that we haven't used in order to come up
with just regularities
but um i think that's
also pretty cool and actually one thing
that um we did
since taping the talk um we looked at
this local search stuff from i'm colin
white
that sort of motivated um
going away from these really small
tabular benchmarks because it did really
um well on the small ones and not on
darts and
found that it didn't do well on darts in
the first few iterations
that's all that calling um actually had
resources to run
and afterwards it actually did really
well and now we're running this on the
true dart space and it looks like it's
also doing really well there so
it's we can use these um benchmarks
in order to actually come up with
hypotheses that we can then test in in
real life um on the real um benchmark
and then we kind of also need to close a
loop and do that
and not only um stick to surrogate
benchmarks yeah no i agree but that's
that's really interesting i didn't know
this after the taping discovery that's
kind of interesting
um i guess i have one question and since
you started
talking and answering other questions
i've kind of gone back a little bit from
it but
hearing your talk i was curious what's
the objective function what's the loss
you use for your surrogate to evaluate
your surrogate or to train it
are you looking at root means whatever
are you looking yeah
well root means great error and also
candles tau and correlation coefficients
okay so so that was kind of my question
because so
my prior was you really care so so
probably with nas bench 101 you've seen
it's nice bench 101 you've done a lot of
looking at
the histogram like the distribution of
the uh performances of different
architectures sampled from the space and
you will
probably have noticed that they look
there is an accumulation
around an average performance that is
pretty bad
you know it's relatively good all these
architecture search bases are pretty
good
uh i would say unless you fall in some
kind of really bad all-skip connection
kind of architecture
petal of despair but then um the high
end
is is kind of like a you know very thin
tail to the good architectures and so my
my question was
if you use the root mascara to evaluate
the accuracy of a surrogate model
on such skewed data uh
you're probably not capturing the
fine-grained things that a practitioner
would care about and so maybe i was
thinking
uh a ranking loss like a normalized
discounted cumulative gain would work
better
yeah um that definitely made sense makes
sense and um
we've also thought about that actually
bananas used um a sort of ranking loss
in
in their uh predictive models so um
yeah we thought about actually putting
that into our surrogates
and it's true we could also put that
into our evaluation number
we haven't done that um it's a good
point it would be
super interesting to see and i guess but
the reason why i changed my mind after
you started talking is because you were
talking about the the generation in the
dart search space where you start
just or the search algorithm rather
where you can just start
feeling the architecture with skip
connects and that
metric wouldn't really capture this so
if because you kind of care about the
you know the the very well high
performing architectures and the very
badly performing once and dcg would have
to do it
you know reversed yeah so so what we did
do is some some qualitative
analyses like this um like for the real
architectures look what happens if we
add more skip connections and then look
in
the model what happens if you do that so
these more more qualitative analyses but
in in terms of the quantitative analysis
i think doing the ranking loss um
absolutely makes sense
um i forgot one thing just to say about
the sparsity of the search base
so i mean if you just think of these
search spaces are not very very high
dimensional right and
if you have i don't know 30 dimensional
data
and you have 50 000 data points in data
science
nobody would say oh it's very hard to
predict something in there right
um this should definitely be possible
and there's also this open graph
benchmark where um
yeah they're collecting um predictive
predictive tasks with graphs and we're
talking
um to them to actually get our data set
in there to also
um yeah get other people working on it
and there's lots of graph neural
networks out there that
that are looking at performance
prediction for nas and and well
this is not the only one and um
so i think that it's a pattern that
there is pretty predictability there for
sure
super interesting um i have you know oh
we are actually at times so i'm going to
hold my question for when we meet
later because this is a virtual visit
after all all right and i want to thank
you again this was a it was an
awesome talk uh and uh it's going to be
available i think on our youtube channel
i feel like
like an influencer saying this but we do
make these available
so thank you again for virtually
visiting okay
thank you very much for the invitation
and for the opportunity to speak
and thanks for all the awesome questions
on in the chat that are great
all right thank you bye-bye thanks